welcome to this video this is Maradona
Maradona from Iceland I'm going for
something else here okay we transpose
into my Zurich variation of them of the
NIMS own could have almost expected that
but okay at least um i have experienced
and some knowledge about this long
castles that's really uncommon Wow okay
there are some ideas with long castling
in the in this line but it's mostly when
black has played age 6 yeah in this sun
and the structures a little bit stunned
here to be honest
I mean it's nothing particularly
worrisome but still that he just
canceled longer that this doesn't happen
solve okay I think I mean be three years
the normal reaction here to make sure
know what is he doing here really this
is this is good I don't I really don't
know right h4 might be my hacking 97-95
cannot be that bad sometimes night h4 is
an ID n this type of positions night age
for Bishop e2 night at five but yeah I
am interesting taking a night C fibers
might be might be a tad passive this is
continuation but I can go with B 5
that's it's like that's actually
interesting I can I can play for be five
before him his king is on the queenside
this wouldn't be a good thing if his
king was on g1 then with before and and
moves like hey I know I get in b5 before
and this is definitely definitely I
giving me some chances we should not oh
no this this isn't good really if this
isn't good what what what is Danielle we
with the King on the other side of the
board it's a it's a different matter but
not not like this okay going for before
I don't see how he prevents that really
before possibly be three yeah rook c8 or
9797 Bishop g4 maybe 97's threatening
discoveries with the night and this is
after all a good structure as well so
why not b4 b4 looks you want I can take
on a three first and then play possibly
Ruby 50 is just closing down the whole
business here okay I don't mind that
very much if we trade everything and I
put the night on c5 at the end it still
should be good but do I want to trade
everything that's that's the other
that's the question really 97 could be
five takes Knight b6 check should be
going on check now the queen bee 5i can
take a Knight b6 and then run and then
running over with the King and probably
will get the b5 pond and if it's not
playing Caribbean that I'm going to hear
for the ideal night placement okay then
then the knight returns to c5 and I'm
always attacking both efore and b3 with
a really nice endgame
okay so how do I proceed g6 and King to
g5 or what now Jim maybe I cannot win
this that's possible it's it's very nice
but it's maybe not not possible to win
yeah I know I'm putting it on a light on
light squares but I really don't see
another way forward besides g5g five
while I have 65
this also f5 f5 takes takes Bishop takes
I can take be three I can't play at five
this takes King g6 then again yeah this
is right this is the right way to go I
guess I can take a play f4 maybe maybe
this is this is saving him and then f4
hmm possible
going for Knight b6 might be six and
winning the pawn king d3 and still
winning the pawn
it's with the chick time what question
is that but okay if he goes to d3 i will
take f form and this is over the tempo
nuts in here I can do this actually can
do this going to see three you see for
that's also not III like resign it's
really losing if you go something I go
here and I have all those squares
controlled and my parts are also running
yeah it was a bad end game for wide i'm
not sure if it should do whispered it is
some it is critical I here I could have
played at five already at this would be
much more aggressive but ok where where
did you really spoil it I really thought
that here it still should be somewhat
okay here i went here here d3 should be
one seems to be better yeah probably am
because now if i go here now we can take
then not the same that h5 is still on
the attack maybe this is this is enough
to draw at least this is watching the
comp is giving with d7 and stuff like
that g-form withdrawn yeah if the
compass giving 000 a such an open
position
yeah what why do what this yeah maybe I
somehow hear that there should have been
some channel may be keeping Queens on
the board but I really this is so
tempting are putting the night on c5 the
ideal square and then just grinding away
you know this is what the compass giving
I understand if I can keep the Queen's
on this is the there is some point to it
but I was always thinking he has some
activity but this is probably yeah that
I can just do this he will have he needs
to protect this ultimately I guess yeah
and stuff like that and there's also
this move attending things like that
this is a really stupid piece yeah some
somewhere there I had had better
something better than this end game
which was probably a draw with best play
okay thanks for watching